you mentioned chicago you're a big cubs
fan yes die hard cubs fan yes and we're
going to the world series in 2025
yeah it's it's it's rough it's rough but
i grew up in wrigleyville that's so
funny because i lived there once years
ago i lived in wrigleyville uh and
this is years ago well it's it's a it's
a great place to visit not a great place
to live unless if you like waking up to
like obese men urinating
near your bed yes
that's what i like
i have that sound i have an app that
makes that sound when i wake up
yeah fat guy pee yeah that guy p honey
i'm gonna set it for fat guy peter night
four yeah uh but it's rough but i'm a
cubs fan are you a north side or south
yeah no cubs fan yet yeah because
there's a big you know uh schism in
rivalry in chicago the north siders are
cubs fans and uh south siders are sox
fans and kind of
uh stocks fans cub fans like oh they're
a bunch of you know university of
michigan little [ __ ]
right and cub fans like i could talk
times like oh you have no teeth and
you're an animal right right and they're
both right right right right that's
right
the cubs fans are the classy fat guys
being under yeah yeah
at the low class they have some college
yeah yeah yeah and uh but i used to go
uh the cubs would play the socks every
year in this game called the crosstown
classic right and it was usually fights
just breaking out every two minutes and
i remember i went into the bathroom and
like you know you know the feeling where
a fight's about to break out
like no no no
[Laughter]
but but this fight's about to break out
and it was so many people in a closed
space that like you could tell people
would die like i could already see the
dateline
about this event like unfolding before
my eyes
and so like a contingent of cubs fans
here and these socks fans are screaming
at them and just as the fight's about to
break out some guy i don't know who he
is he just works himself in between the
crowd and goes hey hey hey
green bay
[Music]
and
our hatred
our hatred for green bay is stronger
than any interesting rivalry which is
good so and he was a magical man right
wonderful man he's a hero i mean it's a
hero uh
it's the third season now mindy project
anything we can be looking for this
season
um yeah well i think that's when you
work with people for a long time you
start to get comfortable and you break a
lot
and break means you start you start to
laugh you got to do your lines and you
laugh yeah and like i used to be a good
actor
and i'm no longer i know i know i know i
thought i could kind of sneak that in
there and uh with andy on one oh no he's
telling me like i hawk this guy uh but
now like me and mindy and musia we just
openly break and like when you're an
actor and you break it's fun you know
it's like mindy we i'm sorry let's start
again you know and
the people that hate that uh is the crew
yes
like our s boom mic operator brian
little is like
he's holding he's holding that stick
with him i've been holding this for 13
hours i want to go see my kids i hate
you all i'm going to kill you all right
you guys are having a good time aren't
you yeah my shoulders hurt yeah
and it's so it's a little it's kind of
the only
business you can break in is acting
right you know you can't like be a cop
and be like
man we found your husband's body
we gotta do this again hold on hold on
this guy's making faces
freeze
i mean airline pilot like uh we're
running low on fuel and uh get ready for
the emergency
the co-pilot's cracking me up
do that it's only actors are afforded
that we're very fortunate we are we're
we're a lucky bunch uh
the mindy project don't
hurt the strongest you're not to touch
him again
he belongs to me
crazy